American Horror Story has been able to
bring back many of its cast members
again and again in new roles every
season without pouring viewers why
because the show's makeup and
personality transformations have made
the actors virtually unrecognizable from
one year to the next here are the best
American Horror Story on-screen
transformations so far
Ethel Darling Kathy Bates has had many
memorable roles on American Horror Story
over the years but her character from
freakshow is perhaps her most iconic yet
in the fourth season Bates played Ethel
Darling a world-weary bearded lady with
such a no-nonsense attitude that
audiences could sometimes even forget
the facial hair was even there Papa
Legba when you get keeper to the spirit
world you'd better look the part in
American Horror Story coven Lance
Reddick did just that as the voodoo
inspired Papa Legba and was completely
convincing as the otherworldly character
Aileen Wuornos Lily rabe had big shoes
to fill when it came to playing
real-life serial killer Aileen Wuornos
after all Charlize Theron won an Oscar
for her portrayal in 2003 s monster rave
offered a sauntering performance for
American Horror Story hotel but her
methodical mannerisms are just part of
the creepiness makeup artists turned her
into a shiver inducing dead ringer for
the notorious murderer pepper American
Horror Story Asylum featured plenty of
unique characters but none stood out
more than the diminutive pepper a lot of
makeup went into overhauling not only
Grossman's appearance for the role it
took two people nearly three hours to
apply the prosthetic details fake teeth
contact lenses makeup each day Grossman
even shaved most of her head for the
role Liz Taylor Denis O'Hara's
transformation into a transgender woman
for American horror stories fifth season
was thorough and not just on the outside
aside from the makeup and outfits O'Hare
gave a nuanced performance that showed
the emotional impact transitioning can
have Liz Taylor was the heart and soul
of the hotel Cortez and she was simply
fabulous I'm sorry
lady this is a no-tell motel penny if
you didn't already know Grace Gummer is
Meryl Streep's daughter you would have
had a tough time seeing the resemblance
in American Horror Story freak show to
achieve her look as lizard girl Gummer
endured daily application of an
elaborate puzzle of prosthetic tattoos
that covered her entire head and neck
although her forked tongue was added in
post-production she did sometimes still
have to wear a silicon applique as well
infant tada
Frankenstein had nothing on in pintada
the late bin wolf played the miniature
monstrosity in season One's murder house
and the character was stunning as the
reanimated remnants of the murdered
Montgomery child who's also ravenous for
blood to capture the unsettling look
wolf had to submit to one heck of a
makeup boo team twisty the clown it took
a hefty amount of special effects talent
to bring twisty the clown to life for
American Horror Story freak show in case
you've somehow managed to erase the
image of his origins from your
nightmares
twisty shot off his jaw with a shotgun
leaving him horribly disfigured beneath
his mask no amount of makeup could make
actor John Carroll Lynch really look
that way though so crew members would
paint his face green and cover it with
motion capture sensors for the chilling
CGI effects Tate Langdon actor Evan
Peters character and murder house didn't
usually look all that different from
Evan Peters in real life but when Tate
applied skull makeup before embarking on
his horrific killing spree it was
thoroughly terrifying and became an
instant favorite force in chala wean
costuming hypodermic Sally Sarah Paulson
was certainly no newcomer to the
American Horror Story franchise when she
suited up as a drug-addled ghost to
haunt the hotel Cortez although she also
played those memorable conjoined twins
Bette and dot and freakshow she's almost
more unrecognizable as hypodermic Sally
with her frazzled hair and ghoulish
makeup especially since she was doubling
down on Ryan Murphy's other FX hit the
People vs OJ Simpson at the same time
with an entirely different appearance
Myrtle snow Frances Conroy's memorable
Taran is Myrtle snow was an obvious
tribute to fashionista Grace Coddington
coven and was a brutally stoic but
honest witch who didn't even flinch when
burned at the stake
those who remembered Conroy best for her
prior TV work as Ruth on
speed under probably wouldn't even
recognize her beneath all that hair and
flair Edward mordrake
weird facial hair is nothing new for
actor West Bentley he'd already done it
in 2012 The Hunger Games before he
joined the crazy crew of American Horror
Story freak show but it wasn't just his
next-level facial hair that made his
take on Edward mordrake so memorable the
19th century Britta forted an extra face
on the back of his head thanks for
watching for more spooky videos our
friends at grunge recently published a
video about the scariest clowns caught
on camera click the video here or the
link in our description to watch it now
if you like looper you'll love grunge
the same team makes videos for both
channels
[Music]